souvenez-vous après avoir complètement
craqué son slip sur un jeu de nommer un
père mario avec des gens retournaient
leur tour sera à peu près le même jeu
cette fois on n'est pas mario on est
quatre mario un peu d'elle quand même
comme comme non non mais tu vas fermer
oui pardon c'est exactement la même
chose que de faire mario il ya des
pièges un peu partout sauf que cette
fois c'est largement plus dur tout le
monde sait ce quiz et ça fait une heure
le temps que je passe les réglages tout
j'essaie [ __ ] de musique odieuse dans
les oreilles j'en ai déjà marre
aujourd'hui on est sur un jeu qui
ressemble fortement à le faire mario
donc le jeu de la vidéo précédente
souvenez vous on a quand même déjà bien
nager il faut bien le dire cette fois
c'est iv mario donc on est un petit
chien mais ca prends les mêmes principes
que mario alors n'est pas autonome auto
moto voilà alors à notre plus grand
bonheur la musique n'est pas la même
quand on joue un bon et tout aussi
dégueulasse faut savoir que j'étais allé
jusqu à un certain endroit déjà dans ce
niveau là la preuve j'ai oublié ne vous
fiez pas aux trois vies c'est totalement
du mytho c'est juste que mais café jeu
est un gros pervers et qui voulez vous
presser ouais gros walla should they
want what is mas 36 truc à la fois sur
ce jeu ok on y retourne bon si on
pourrait au moins passer près niveau
j'avoue que je suis assez fier de nous
enfin le chat de merde way up on y est
le flag caisse non et je le prend le
trou que tu es large de base au port
alors cette fois l'avantagé qu'on n'a
pas besoin de marteler notre barre
espace quand on meurt 1
au moins on ne perdra pas nos claviers
wata ouais les pépins de perverse et
père ken faire mario ok on y retourne
ouf j'avais il descend pour montrer
intra-équipe faut que je tombe dans un
trou qui n'existait même pas
[ __ ] bon je disais vous avez vu il ya
l'homme courgettes juste la voix
peut-être un jour y arriver voilà on y
est hop sud vers le truc là ça je me
souviens [ __ ] de pluie de boo boo
c'est un personnage dans mario kart qui
était plutôt comme eux en fait un
fantôme une boule blanche avec une
bouche et les yeux sur tv par le voit la
[ __ ] de forme de merde on passe le
tuer au vert on esquive le nuage oui le
nuage est vilain le cube le cutting mais
on est au premier niveau
cointat le jeu il va t'en as hautmont ce
petit cul pas du côté pair de la force
enfin dans son nuage disque à montcuq
l'est on esquive l'appui de boue [ __ ]
mais son sérieux peut-être mario ou le
jeu impossible à faire en speed run à
cause de de [ __ ] développeurs fourbe
de merde qui est tombée des pièges
inexistant un peu aux quatre coins de la
map
chez qu'on peut monter là dessus [ __ ]
voilà voilà
si vous êtes demandé quatre maillots
diomède tu continues je t'amène catwomen
c'est l'effet tpv un simple blague était
nulle totalement nuls en continu ont
passé qui s'il ya un piège
[ __ ] j'ai dit en plus
non le nuage vilain wimereux sa mère
alors vais retourner parce que d'après
la propriété de l'action circonflexe si
on recommence au bout de quarante six
fois on devrait y arriver avec un taux
de rage équivalent au taux d'obésité eux
dans un mcdo voilà alors la cij esquif
pas le laser le butin très jaune qui
nous a tué tout à l'heure je pète un
câble je vous dis d avance alors
attendez demain est parti mon kiki c'est
ce qui ma grand mère disait quand
j'étais en c b
je ne savais pas marché
je me rappelle à la barbe pour pour pour
pompon pour montrer mon manteau de
réflexion watts
donc mon chien est coincé dans ce cube à
aa
on a dû scier le jeu aaa à aa
attention ce qui va suivre est
extrêmement rageant surtout gardez votre
calme
ouais c'est bon ben là c'est bon quoi
mais ces raisons une animation qui nous
tue
faut-il être con moi je n'enrage pas
quand je meure jamais à l'oeil qui sort
de nulle part ça c'était pas mal ça mais
je le connais par coeur et niveau que
c'est bon d'avoir un jeu qu'ils
veuillent bat pas comment on fait
parfois
[ __ ] je vois tu sais même pas j'y
crois pas je ne touchais même pas j'y
crois pas de toucher même pas si crois
pas je ne touchais même pas
un peu assez drôle un médium à côté
argent et site ou malte en droit il
faudra bien remonter dès qu'il a visé
d'avoir et pourquoi faire sauter allez
on part sur une réussite cette fois
c'est sûr et certain hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop c'est le moment où tu fais rien
de la vidéo le moment sienne tu dois
attendre que les femmes passent mais la
vidéo alors j'ai pris sur moi même et le
café de mon cas ce qu'a fait rêver tour
alors cette fois pourrions nous y
arriver à l'est alors maintenant on a
plus qu'à
basi ce que je pourrais rentrer dans la
maison c'est une blague
c'est une blague easy lafargue engelman
pas connaître mais higuain insiders
parfois fausses factures mandat frise
please please give me guide c'est la
maison hantée de 1772 avant jésus-christ
lorsque la mère la vierge francisco du
bal a actuellement une chaîne traduire
une nouvelle page pour voir les touches
d'ordre à toi ça ne nous avance pas
vraiment bon si quelqu'un qui regarde
cette vidéo aurait une idée de la touche
sur lequel appuyer pour avoir accès à
ces [ __ ] de maison bon eh bien c'est
simple nous venons de jouer 20 minutes
et un jeu sur lequel nous n'avons pas
passé le premier niveau aaa
je comprends pas quand tu passe au
dessus tu veux pas rentrer quand tu
passes de suite à une animation tu te
fais but et a eu des rigolos de coincer
les joies
bon allez je remercie d'avoir gagné
cette vidéo mais bon si je ne sais pas
comment aller au bout de la maison à la
fin de la map que dois-je faire que
puis-je faire un appart tomber dans le
corps ce [ __ ] de pièges de pervers
l'as fait dix fois enix tombe de denges
dalmat fait très peur si vous avez la
réponse n'hésitez pas à dire en
commentaire je pourrais éventuellement
posté le deuxième épisode dès demain 1
ça serait quand même une belle chose et
maintenant portez vous bien et puis
profitez bien de vos vacances tient tout
le monde pis épique